[Musique]
oh mais qu'at elle était à détecter sur
l'île de la réunion c'est un homme de 53
ans il a voyagé au mozambique a fait
escale en afrique du sud en état de
santé n'est pas dans les cas de sévérité
donc pour l'instant pas de sévérité mais
quels symptômes or des symptômes
classiques à vous avez là tout vous avez
des douleurs musculaires il a six
personnes contacts à risque 3 de son
entourage professionnel et 3 de sa
famille proche qui évidemment sont à l'
isolement et qui vont être testés
régulièrement il n'y a pas de raison de
paniquer nous disposant du meilleur
vaccin au monde des meilleurs
médicaments des meilleurs scientifiques
et nous en apprenons chaque jour
davantage sur la façade du panthéon les
grandes étapes de la vie de joséphine
baker sont projetés diva du music-hall
résistante pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
militante contre le racisme s qu'eric
zemmour comme l'écrit libération est
devenu l'idiot utile de marine le pen
jeu est très haut je suis pas
journaliste commentateur mais tu vois un
homme seul polémiste de métier qui fait
très bien ce métier là et qui veut
s'improviser président de la république
parce qu'il s'est mis en tête de vouloir
sortir la france du déclin c'est
pourquoi
j'ai décidé de me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
j'ai donc décidé de solliciter vos
suffrages devenir votre président de la
république mais les caps ont nom cap au
nord c'est vraiment un truc de 4 points
alors je dois dire je suis infligé ces
poltrons pardon
eric zemmour est à la politique ce que
la série z est à l'oeuvre
cinématographique et c'est vrai que sa
déclaration reflète ce que le cinéma
peut faire de plus mauvais ce que la
politique manifestement peut faire de
plus mauvais le micro de de gaulle mais
le discours de pétain la bibliothèque de
pompidou mais les lettres de renaud
camus la musique de beethoven mais les
fausses notes d'un passé fantasmé pour
un présent caricaturer la france ne
mérite pas cette sinistre mise en scène
les plus l'impression que c'était une
déclaration avec 100 présidentielle de
1965 de celle de 2022 c'est peut-être
son côté vintage donc c'est tout sauf
une surprise et puis c'est une tentative
de rattrapage et c'est un rattrapage qui
a raté puisque la mise en scène est
grotesque
effectivement en plus s'il n'avait même
pas demander les droits pour certaines
images nous on a une chaîne youtube et
effectivement on sait très bien qu'on
est vite rattrapé par la patrouille des
boutiques et une chanson
n'est pas eric zemmour un peu plus
d'ennemis que la moyenne
dans ce pays il ya des empreintes des
images et extraits de films apparemment
venait pas demander les droits est ce
que c'est une maladresse c'est ce qu'on
avait oubliées
les querelles de juristes douanes
s'intéresser aux juristes moi je ne
m'occupe pas de ça
la vidéo
diffusée de ne pas courir les plateaux
pour vous féliciter du futur travail que
vous aurez avec lui mais plutôt de
rester dans l'arc républicain dit depuis
le xviiie siècle que on persécute
toujours ce qui sonne le tocsin et au
contraire on est aimable avec ceux qui
mettent le feu donc ceux qui me
reprochent d'exacerber les tensions se
sont eux qui mettent le feu en ne
faisant rien depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans
je crois qu'en tout cas les avant même
sa candidature les français ont déjà pu
se rendre compte du style eric zemmour
va dire c'est pas des doigts d'honneur
aux français voilà je veux dire ça ça
témoigne quand même de quelque chose on
nous a vendus il nous a vendus qu'il
était le trump français assez un train
peut commander sur we show comme on dit
les héros suspens comme la zéro
programme comme il ya zéro maîtrise de
soi le mieux à 0 équipe avant l'identité
de chacun
l'hospitalité pour toutes les
différences réunis par une même volonté
une même dignité
ma france
c'est joséphine c'est l'exemple même de
la réussite du modèle d'assimilation à
l'ancienne que je veux restaurer et que
nos élites et en particulier emmanuel
macron des tests et rejette donc voyez
moi je dis oui je sais fine bakker c'est
la france